I don't and I never will understand why
leaders don't understand that a 3-minute
call can create so much upside or the
individual on the other side of the call
you as a leader and and most of all
which is always my first priority the
logo at hand
people always say things like it blows
me away Gary how much time you have to
engage with your fans on social people
always say I can't believe you you take
those five minutes to say hello when
people don't see as much and what the
LAV allows me to do is you know this
three minute call three minutes 180
seconds could be the difference between
this individual being with us for 10 to
15 years and he's an amazing guy versus
gone in 10 and 15 weeks like I don't
think people get it people your asset
too many of you are thinking so
short-term you're like yeah you took
three minutes on that but then the guy
leaves and does his own thing and then
what doing the right thing is always the
right thing like putting in that 180
seconds is always ROI positive